les séries après dix mois de rigolade
les chroniqueurs vont être séparés
pendant les vacances d'été
vous le savez ils ont donc décidé
d'écrire une lettre d'adieu à certaines
personnes et moi je parlerai à vous au
public dans un instant à 20 heures et je
crois que il ya quatre lettres
je crois que valérie vous avez écrit une
lettre à qui géraldine maillet est pas
vrai ces lettres
moi j'ai écrit une lettre également à
élise sinon c'est la culture ça c'est la
culture tu vas en faire la culture des
prochaines sépare qui est obligé de
prendre un micro ne changerait les mecs
il ya sept personnes sont ici on nous
l'a ont réagi le haut niveau ma chère
géraldine qu'est ce qu'une amie
c'est une soeur qu'on a choisi je t'ai
choisi tu fais partie de ma vie ma soeur
mon ami nous nous sommes rencontrés il
ya plus de 15 ans maintenant au détour
d'un couloir d'une maison d'édition
quelques mots échangés un début de
complicité le hasard de la vie a fait
que quelques heures plus tard nous nous
retrouvions à un mariage et ce soir là
c'est comme si nous nous étions nous
marier un mariage d'amitié une évidence
parce que c'était toi parce que c'était
moi alors parce que c'est écrit comme ça
manuela lopez je ne dirais pas ici les
détails de notre amitié mais je dirais
ici à quel point j'ai pu éprouver la
solidité ton amitié à toute épreuve la
droiture morale costaud et on ouverture
d'esprit tu n'es jamais là où on attend
toujours a confié les jamais avec la
meute est toujours un pas de côté
et pour tout cela je t'admire autant que
je t'aime
j'ajouterai parce que sinon c'est trop
sérieux à quel point on rit également
toutes les deux on a des fous rires
mémorables
j'arrête là cette lettre ma déclaration
d'amour à une soeur de coeur entré dans
ma vie il ya quinze ans et qui n'en
sortira jamais même pendant les vacances
très beau
[Applaudissements]
non mais en plus tu écris très bien
valérie devrais je sais pas si tu as lu
son dernier ouvrage qu'il faut en série
non mal écrit bien elle écrit très mais
c'est vous êtes de la maison d'édition
avec m mais qu'est ce qu'une amie nature
vous aussi qu'est ce qu'un connard alors
les toits le droit d'être ému parfois on
a on a on a une deuxième lettre je crois
que ces gens me je sais pas pour qui il
a écrit cette lettre
merci et bon match mais excusez moi mais
sans micro qui marche messieurs jeune
tchèque que quoi tout le côté là qui
pensent je te parler d'accord on a comme
moi on comprend la baisse des salaires
on n'en veut pas on comprend en effet
difficile toute façon je vais vous dire
la vérité c'est surtout avec ce côté là
que fait l'émission ça nous va bien une
caméra franchement je savais que côté là
alors on y va
mon mathieu à 20h15 nous serons en
vacances mais tu sais que mon amitié
pour toi n'en prendra pas de vacances
pour ceux qui suivent pas quand tu es
entré dans la famille des pnp il ya cinq
ans j'ignorais là parce que tu prendrais
dans ma vie aujourd'hui j'en suis ravi
pas un jour sans qu'on s'appelle
consomme à oak on se remonte le moral
bref qu'on se partage nos petites vies
voilà je ne sais pas si tu as espère un
jour coucher avec moi mais l'essentiel
est que tu es déclaré il ya quelque
chose me coucher sur ton testament voilà
ne tarissent pas faire machine arrière
j'ai demandé l'enregistrement de ce
passage la production et mon notaire en
une copie de façon plus professionnelle
je voulais surtout te dire ce soir que
tu est pour moi le meilleur chroniqueur
un vrai showman drôle percutant dans ses
analyses
bourré de talent est toujours sincères
devant moi vous n'êtes pas produit ici
tout le monde t'aime et moi je suis fier
de tes mais un peu plus beaucoup plus
que les autres je t'embrasse
c'est mignon semenya montlouis kelly n'a
pas les pas pardon pour la paix reid non
mais attendez mais comment on va faire
des sondés confiné déjà quand vous avez
un homme un vrai j'étais en pleurs
valérie comment vas tu sais pas pour les
autres mais moi ça commence à beaucoup
de manques et l'on se rend pas compte à
quel point le monde on voit s'embrasser
peu qu'on peut pas surcharger
humainement et tout ça devient difficile
à jouer bref personne notamment jean mi
mais c'est difficile
amélie s'est ému 13 c'est très beau ce
qu'il écrit lui aussi décrit très bien
les chercher et monsieur tresses et
c'est très touchant et c'est vrai le
juste pour lui répondre trois secondes
que c'est vraiment une rencontre
jean-louis c'est vrai mais j'adore tout
le monde adore valérie ya plein de gens
que j'adore mes jambes me c'est autre
chose c'est mon grand frère parce qu'un
grand frère un ami
c'est un frère qu'on a choisi pour moi
c'est ça qui est chroniqueur cdu ces
deux clés noires alors que le patron il
vous a choisis quand tu nous emmerdes la
mine rio et oui pardon mais on respecte
ma vie là où regarder dans les calanques
et des lilas ou s'il vous plaît non
micro marche ouais vous a écrit une
lettre à qui la montée bas côtés comme
je savais pas pour qui écrire cette
lettre j'ai décidé de me l'a dressé
[Rires]
je ne suis sûr de rien alors c'est assez
émouvant bouclé cher bernard
voilà maintenant trois ans que tu as
divinement bien intégré l'équipe de tpm
paix est devenu complètement fou je suis
très ému il est mentaliste mes débuts
ont été remarqués par cyril notre dieu
normal c'est toujours l'effet produit
par le génie lorsqu'ils sortent de la
lampe et je t'apprendrai rien en disant
que certaines jalouse c'est toujours à
moi je parle pas seulement boutons
physiques et approchable il devenu fou
mais aussi pour ton talent oui mon
talent car réunir 11 millions de
téléspectateurs sur vidéo gag avec des
chiens qui pète alors merci d'être
l'homme charismatique que tu es resté
talentueux et humble que tu es bisous
montbernage étaient heureux là bas ouest
et sur derrière je parle de moi
bravo france et ses dérivés réservé tout
son talent pour la dernière semaine
il est de mieux en mieux non chez un
grand comédien il est excellent bah je
vous ai vu dans sous le soleil était
bien je bénis ça devient écrire une
lettre où des cris à qui mon banquier
très ému
habib sy alors il ya nourdine tu me dis
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est nette pour
moi aa oui c'est qui le soutient la
laisser pour ce que tu peux le faire
dans un instant franchement j'écris
jamais bas il écrit jamais mais ça passe
on espérait mieux mais oui c'est mon
frère d'arnaud alors je me souviens de
ce rendez vous avec toi pour faire de la
radio
j'étais tellement flipper que j'ai été
faire pipi trois fois fit est arrivé et
tu m'as dit t'inquiète pas j'adore tes
cheveux c'est bon c'est signé j'ai pas
pu aller jusqu'au bout de la saison j'ai
arrêté avant la fin à cause des
livraisons tu m'a regardé dans les yeux
et tu m'as dit raymond si tu t'amuses
plus faut partir est athée livraison va
faire tes livraison mais regarde moi
bien sûr la tête de ma mère que je lâche
pas je me suis dit bon c'est des phrases
qu'on dit comme ça dans ce métier là à
mon avis la suite tu la connais je la
connais l'amitié s'installe nos texto on
échange ton envie de me remettre à
chaque fois à l'antenne de pas me lâcher
touche pas à mon sport l'an pense quoi
tp mp3 fois trois échecs
tu viens me voir es tu me dis ça
marchera jamais citer pas toi-même les
conseils toujours les conseils la
bienveillance malgré nos désaccords tu
cherche toujours à me protéger tel un
grand frère pendant l'émission mais
surtout après démission
alors oui j'ai rencontré des vedettes
j'ai rencontré des chroniqueurs
extraordinaires ici des gens
intelligents que j'avais jamais vu dans
mon monde à moi ça n'existait pas des
gens comme ça kim qui m'apprennent des
choses je t'ai vu par là des
agriculteurs des ministres des gilet
jaune des gens galèrent à quito faire
des maisons devant moi ça je le voyais à
la télé ça ne faisait rien devant moi ça
me faisait pleurer après dans mon boulot
les gens me disaient bravo raymond
continue comme ça à la télé ça motive et
ça motivait pour toutes ces raisons je
suis contente que la vie mais fait
croiser ton chemin
je suis fier d'être près de toi je suis
fier d'être ton pote mon cyril hanouna
cela distrait ma vie je t'aime série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon frère
alors ouais franchement mérité c'est
plus du tout à l'heure mais décrit très
bien c'est la vérité parce que c'est ça
vient du plat commun ce qui se passe
c'est pas commun de prendre un livre à
réduire une fois tu vas faire de la télé
le mec fait de la merde c'est pas y
retourner il fait de la merde et
troisième fois tu vas y arriver quand tu
seras toi même et y avoue c'est vrai la
saison a été longue
je me suis parfois énervé plusieurs fois
j'ai eu des accrochages avec mathieu
mais faut que les gens sachent que c'est
des gens qu'on a pu me tirer dans les
pattes c'est des gens qui auraient pu me
mettre de côté quand on a pu ne pas
m'aider à chaque fin d'émission
et quand tu ne sais combien de fois j'ai
voulu me barrer s'est dit demain je me
bats tous les textos que j'ai reçu de
chacun t'inquiète pas ça va aller c'est
comme ça à la télé voilà je voudrais
dire aux gens quand on parle de famille
il ya ceux qui nous aiment pas et c'est
pas grave continue et pas nous aimer
c'est votre choix et ceux qui nous
aiment
mais quand on parle de famille allait
elle est là quoi que vous pensiez allait
quand même là la famille